well the Vegas Golden Knights of course
captured the hearts of fans six years
ago when they came on the scene and love
for the team has only continued to grow
as they skate towards the Stanley Cup
and we've been learning that young fans
are taking their love to the ice our
Candace Charles is live at the Las Vegas
Ice Center where the Las Vegas storm
Junior Hockey Teams not only showing
their cute Candace they're showing us
their skills
and honestly Nate they're telling us a
little bit about how you know what the
knights are probably going to take it
home and I like that energy we need that
energy right now don't we we really do
and I'm joined by Matt held their coach
as well thank you so much for joining us
say hi guys
people all right now I know it all
starts on the ice very young right to
get two of that cup right so a little
bit about that Journey it's a it's a
long process these guys put in a lot of
work every single day they come to the
rink early before school and they really
work their butts off to try and get to
where they're at absolutely and
the network of their website right guys
children
to say about it oh he'll played an
amazing game really the knights was a
really good team effort and we won yes
absolutely and I know we're getting
close to the end guys how are we feeling
about getting the Stanley Cup how are we
feeling about taking it home what do you
think what do you think good I think
good yeah I think we're gonna win in
Florida I think we're gonna win in four
games yes all right we're feeling asleep
I'm liking it I'm liking it all right
can you give me one one last thing say a
good go nights for me real quick one two
three
amazing thank you guys you guys so much
energy here I'm feeling that I'm excited
I hope you guys are excited but for now
live from the Las Vegas Eye Center I'm
Candace Charles in his dad